a major night of news involving the
alleged sale of presidential pardons
sexual harassment anti-semitic remarks
all sorts of allegations against Rudy
Giuliani Donald Trump is implicated in
these allegations and we'll get to that
sort of subsequently but let's start
with where this all began which is a
lawsuit the lawsuit has been filed by
Noel Dunphy we are naming her despite
her status as the alleged Victim Because
she has gone public this is not a
situation where uh there is a Jane Doe
who's uh looking to remain anonymous at
least publicly Daily Beast article
explains harassment suit against Rudy
Giuliani full of graphic allegations a
New York woman says the ex-mayor
sexually harassed her while she was
working for him claims that he
previously denied when you look at the
article you learn about the 70-page
complaint filed in New York Supreme
Court
this goes back to January where Noelle
dunfee filed the summons says she was
hired by Rudy in 2019 for so-called
Business Development work that he did
not pay her as promised and subsequently
fired her in 2021. the summons also
alleges that Rudy Giuliani made
anti-semitic and racist remarks during
quote confused and hostile alcohol-laced
tirades and demanded sexual favors the
lawsuit was filed Monday remember the
first step was the summons in January we
now have a lawsuit the lawsuit includes
extraordinary detail much of it probably
inappropriate for this show it includes
allegations of forced oral sex and
intercourse details of Rudy's sexual
preferences which is gag worthy the
Revelation that Dunphy recorded some of
the interactions there are tapes lordy
there are tapes and the lawsuit seeks 10
million dollars in Damages a statement
was put out by Rudy at Giuliani
vehemently and completely denies the
allegations
plans to thoroughly defend himself that
it is harassment and attempted extortion
uh I don't know that we need to go
through all of these elements but they
relate to demands from Rudy that Dunphy
work naked or in American flag Laden
short shorts that he purchased for her
these are like hyper-specific
allegations I mentioned the forced oral
sex
Rudy talking about fantasies related to
the television show billions that Rudy
was constantly taking Viagra and would
sometimes dear God Point his erect penis
and say work couldn't be done until that
was dealt with
um video conferences would include
requests or demands for disrobing there
were text messages where these are
included the I mean this you know it's
much tougher when there are recordings
and text messages to write this all off
as made up
um requests to shower together
um
it it's all it's all outrageous and then
one of the big elements of this which
we're going to discuss on its own
because it is so outrageous dunfee this
is now from the article dunfee claims
Giuliani told her he was able to quote
break the law
because he has quote immunity
and asked if she knew anyone who needs a
pardon because he was selling them for
two million dollars
he told Miss Dunphy that he she could
refer individuals seeking pardons to him
so long as they did not go through the
normal channels of the office of the
pardon attorney because then they'd be
subject to disclosure and this goes on
and on and on uh 2020's plan in February
2019 the complaint notes Giuliani told
dunfee about Trump's plan if he were to
lose specifically Giuliani said to
Dunphy Trump would claim there was voter
fraud and say he won
this was discussed at several meetings
with Giuliani and Lev parnis this is
absolutely stunning stuff absolutely
stunning stuff there's another article
which we won't go through in details
from Business Insider Rudy hit with
bombshell rape lawsuit ex-staffer says
he demanded oral sex while he took calls
from Donald Trump
um has America ever been more wrong
about someone than about Rudy Giuliani
after 9 11. I mean that's one question
that certainly comes up Bill Cosby I
guess maybe and so much of the last five
years now has to be sort of Revisited or
reinterpreted through the lens of this
lawsuit if you believe it to be credible
and I have no reason at this point uh to
to doubt it there are audio recordings
there are text messages there is this is
genuinely a bombshell when we think back
to that Borat scene Sasha Baron Cohen
where Rudy Giuliani after the fact said
oh I was just tucking in my shirt
it certainly seems less harmless in the
wake of these new allegations Dunphy has
receipts twenty thousand emails text
messages and recordings and let's not
ignore this is a lawsuit this is a civil
proceeding let's not ignore the
potential for some of those documents
and records to become relevant in
potential criminal investigations
against Rudy Giuliani so that's the
lawsuit let's now focus in on the pardon
aspect of this
one of our sponsors today is fume not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad part
from your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning device that does exactly
that fume is not electronic there's no
Vapor or harmful chemicals fume is just
a delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fume success story head on over to
try fumed dot com and use the code
Pacman to save 10 percent when you get
the journey pack which comes with the
device and three flavors the link is
down below